understand that you have a deal with
gravitas did they approach you did you
approach them that work sort of it was
somewhat fortuitous we I was at the film
film inattentive Film Forum and pitched
gravitas ta the film and showed him the
trailer and one of the meetings and they
invited us in to talk and they decided
that they wanted to mr. eat the film on
furphy OD and I mean it was as simple as
that was sort of like I said very
fortuitous and sort of odd how quickly
everything happened so you saw yes
yeah they had they have all of these
panels where different people speak and
I had my iPhone with the trailer and I
went up to multiple people and and
companies and showed them the
distribution houses and show them the
trailer and don't even like oh boy yeah
yeah can you watch myself please we were
lucky we did we just got very lucky and
we I pitched the idea and they watched
to watch the trailer and then like I
said next thing within a couple weeks we
were already in talks of what the deal
was to include goes not the gravitas ad
VOD this is there this is just for VOD
but you have a distribution or you know
we we ultimately did ourselves very very
likely I mean yeah those months of phone
calls and emails follow up follow up
hundreds let me at this point thousands
of emails to theatres
and just endless calls trying to get
picked up or booked in various cities
and I need for all that time n and you
end up with just a few so it's still
it's it's worth it to us because we're
going to be at about you know four to
run for a week in to sit three cities
Portland LA in New York and we'll have
single night screens at about seven
other cities that we've booked ourselves
that we don't do that we don't include
anybody else into any of the profits so
that that was pretty cool and we learned
a lot throughout that process that was
that was a very trying arduous
ridiculous process yeah because we
didn't I mean throughout this whole
process we don't I mean other than Joe
we're ready to create a media company
practic writing for the last five years
just whatever we didn't know how to do
anything we just learned we've read
books or try out the try on everything
so something messed up on the phone or
trying to book a theater then we learn
from our mistake and then try something
different the next time until we booked
are you buying out the theater for that
week for that night or you doing shut
the door some Sun it's it's maybe the
mix between the two yeah
and so how would you initially pitch
these theaters would you do a phone call
first try to get someone on the phone
and talk to them what would you do an
email I would I wouldn't phone call
phone call friend we just call call call
and in fall no until I end up talking to
someone who may actually make a decision
opposed to that's the key that's it yeah
anything actually yeah that's true
there's a lot of people oh yeah a lot of
people want their films played here and
then what does that mean you guys
yeah oh we were all over it so it I just
kept all until I was able to get in
touch with somebody who was able to make
a decision
um at some of those theories we feel
like a friend of a friend of a friend
somehow they had a connection with
somebody and then they put us in contact
with them so we've been very lucky
there's been a lot of hard work and that
if that's gone into making all this
happen but we've caught some serious
breaks so it's been it's been reassuring
and somewhat it's provided us with just
like moments like momentary repose which
is which is most needed at times after
going through such a lengthy unending
process for now two years now it's over
two years since we started yeah two
years two months since we since we
started pre-production so when you call
these theatres if you didn't hear back
in what length of time would you do
follow I just keep calling
I was relentless I was if I didn't hear
back for more than a day I was calling
back today I mean there are yeah so some
some people actually get angry
oh my I think every no I was determined
to try to get us into some some theater
you know even if it wasn't one and then
actually saw our first clip of the movie
on the big screen the other yeah which
was really cool that was very cool music
all three and projectionist was kind
enough to show us three minutes of the
film and we got to hear it and see it
knows really cool well aside from luck
you say you're having all this luck so
it has to be that you're doing something
incredibly right to though to pitch you
know the trailer to gravitas what was
your style how would you approach them
you know you said you were relentless
with the calling of the fears how would
you approach people a person to see
because there was so much at risk here
with credit cards I just wasn't gonna
take no for an answer I mean Brandon
there were four more people that said no
and clearly they had to take their
answer but no wasn't gonna stop me from
asking somebody else so I just was very
fortunate especially with the LA Film
Forum they provided a lot of individual
meetings like one-on-one face time and
once I saw there is an opportunity for
that I thought I'd keep the pitch very
short and simple and more or less let
them decide by watching the trailer if
if we should continue the conversations
and we had a lot of extended meetings
with several distributors for VOD which
was which was awesome but like I said
ultimately one with gravitas I they I
said I'm not understand positive but I
think they appreciated the the the humor
and of our film and I think they
recognized that even although first film
that was very much do-it-yourself with
no budget I think I saw some potential
so I'm sure also I mean I can't speak
for them but you know I probably added
some diversity to their line of lineup
of films you know from no budget to high
budget yeah yeah for sure so I mean I
think yeah I think the third good people
are and/or they have definitely gone to
some lengths to accommodate our film so
it's been a good relationship
you